[Musique]
super méchants
cellules tristes en costumes
voulant que vous pensiez qu'elles sont toutes sombres
et profondes à
quoi ressemble la
vie comme une punchline
[Musique]
mais tout ce que je prendrais
serait un acte béni de
rébellion à restaurer  votre dignité dans son
intégralité
[Musique]
vous savez que l'affaire complète la mission
vous obtenez 10 ans de réduction de votre peine
vous ne suivez en aucune façon mes ordres
et je fais exploser l'engin explosif à
la base de votre crâne
aimez-le ou détestez-le ce sont  tes
frères et soeurs pour les prochains
jours
des questions
et oui c'est ta main très bonne
nous allons tous mourir
j'espère
donc oh pour l'amour de dieu
c'est du
suicide oh c'est un peu notre truc
comme un bain de sang pour commencer le jour où
ils appellent  toi pacificateur
je chéris la paix de tout mon cœur
je me fiche du nombre d'hommes femmes et d'
enfants que je dois tuer pour l'obtenir
je pensais que tu étais un fou oh ouais
voici le deal nous avons échoué une mission tu es
mort nous découvrons toute information  tu
nous donnes c'est faux  mourir si nous découvrons que
vous avez des plaques d'immatriculation personnalisées vous
mourrez quoi non
vous